father and son duo stewart and cedar has
spent 10 years creating a brand new
beehive that takes the sting out of
beekeeping this is literally honey on
tap this clip is sweet what's the
inspiration behind this tasty innovation
harvesting honey isn't easy either for
the beekeeper or for the bees
traditionally you need to get a full
body suit on and carry some kind of
smoker they'll sedate the bees with
smoke then take the honeycomb out of the
hive split it open who move the honey
and try to reassemble it in the hive all
without crushing any bees or getting
stung themselves so how they hacked the
hive to produce honey on tap what Stuart
and Sator have done is pre-made part of
the honeycomb
at the heart of it are these specially
designed frames that have partially
completed hexagonal structure because
the honeycomb structure is incomplete
the bees complete it with wax before
they fill it with honey and then they
ultimately seal it with more wax when
the time is right you turn a key at the
top of the frame and that breaks the
honeycomb structure now the honey is
free to flow down to the bottom of the
hive where you can extract it by turning
the tenderly because the frames never
leave the pie if no bees are crushed in
the process and when the honey harvest
is complete the frames can be realigned
and the bees will once again start
filling those cells with honey and
raising over 13 million in crowdfunding
these are some VI and bees
[Music]